have you ever been in love a long long
time ago damn if you would you so many
times yeah all the time
my life hasn't been what you probably
think it has
we'll have our struggles
[Music]
Steve whatever it is I know no let me do
it it has to be me
I can save today but you can save the
world
[Music]
welcome to the future life is good
but it can be better why shouldn't be
all you need is to watch
now
I take what I want in return everyone
will see
[Music]
nothing good is born from life
and greatness is not what you think
and walnuts you you know you need to do
[Music]
it's all art uh that just is trashcan
it's just a trashcan welcome back
everyone it's Charlie this is gonna be
my new Wonder Woman 1984 trailer video
they also made some big announcements
because of the virus things are being
delayed things are being canceled it's
finally hit the Wonder Woman 1984 movie
- so I'll explain everything that's
going on if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we're doing an Amazon giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know which other big
characters you want Wonder Woman to
cross over with in her next big movies
so we'll start with all the footage then
I'll talk about the big announcements
that Warner Brothers just made about the
movie this is just a new version of the
trailer that's done with more flashbacks
to the first Wonder Woman movie
referencing her past with Steve Trevor
doing a better job of setting up the big
Steve Trevor twist in 1984 in the
present day of the movie if it wasn't
clear from all the trailers and all the
interviews that gal gadot patty Jenkins
and the rest of the cast have done Steve
Trevor is really Steve Trevor during the
movie he really is alive he's magic back
to life it's not a fake it's not some
secret martian manhunter twist
pretending to be Steve Trevor and it has
nothing to do with any of the Wonder
Woman pantheon of gods from the first
movie some of which could still totally
be around in the world to wreak havoc in
Wonder Woman 3 patty Jenkins did reveal
that she does have plans for Wonder
Woman 3 and it won't be set during the
past but within Wonder Woman 1984 it's
not Hades or Zeus or another powerful
Greek god behind all these big twists
the movie still trades a lot on Magic
mythology and gods because all Wonder
Woman's stories do it just not the gods
from the first movie Pedro Pascal who's
been blowing it up on the mandalorian
for the past year is playing Maxwell
Lord and it's the 1980s comic book
version of Maxwell Lord not the early
2000s telepathic version of Maxwell Lord
so Steve Trevor isn't like fake
mindspace Steve Trevor he's physical you
can touch him he can punch people as you
see during all these White House scenes
in the trailers where he's punching
these White House guards with Wonder
Woman Maxwell Lord does get powers
during the movie but it's all because of
what's going on with this special Black
Rock within the context of the movie he
just starts out as an 80s yuppie
businessman who's down on his luck and
searching
a quick way to riches and fame as he
professes through all of his television
ads you can have anything you want all
you have to do is just reach out and
grab it you just have to want it bad
enough a lot of that's trading on the
tropes of the 1980s televangelists and
people who were selling salvation
selling things that didn't turn out to
be real those scenes in the trailer
where he's staring at the special black
rocks so intensely saying now I get what
I want in return
that's when things really start to go
off the rails you have to think of it as
a monkey's paw situation where it's
granting them all these amazing things
but secretly it's also taking a lot from
them in return that also kind of
explains what's going on with the
cheetah character because as you see
cheetah starts out as regular
archaeologist Barbara Minerva who's
super awkward lovelorn
I've been in love so many times all the
time as she's talking to Wonder Woman
over a copy she works at the same Museum
in Washington DC as Wonder Woman
remember Wonder Woman obviously because
she's lived for so long is uniquely
suited to work in antiquities and
because the movie set during the past it
explains why Wonder Woman is working at
this museum and not at the Louvre
because that's where we saw her during
the first Wonder Woman movie they Rick
conned a couple things about her
backstories since Batman vs Superman but
I still think that by the time we get to
present-day she will eventually be
working at the Louvre but as the special
black rock starts messing with
everything and things get crazier and
crazier you sort of see cheetah slowly
become cheetah over the course of the
trailer like she goes from being super
awkward as things start to devolve in
the streets you start to see her become
more confident more sure of herself and
then obviously by the end of the movie
when she goes full comic-book cheetah
the movies mostly about learning the
dangers of trying to cheat to win making
the Star Wars reference because this is
happening during the 80s so we can make
the Empire Strikes Back reference as
Master Yoda would say the quick and easy
way is the path to the dark side so
there's a contrast between the Wonder
Woman character and the cheetah
character coming to that realization in
the cheetah character just being too
afraid to make the right choice Wonder
Woman being the Wonder Woman you expect
her to be making the tough choice to
sacrifice her temporary happiness for
the sake of the world
her happiness obviously being
represented in the Steve Trevor
character so there's a lot of crazy
magic going on behind all this but the
message of the movie is pretty obvious a
lot of people wondering about the
invisible jet
going on with her sword why isn't she
running around with it this time
there is no invisible jet during the
movie despite what some of this footage
makes it look like the scene where
they're flying in a jet is just a normal
jet just more of Steve Trevor being
amazed with modern technology in the
scene where it seems like she's
seemingly flying into the air like she
lassos nothingness and then just flies
into the air and then later when she's
last winged the lightning bolts those
are actually just scenes with unfinished
special effects but she can fly during
the movie it is one of her basic
comic-book abilities but for whatever
reason they decided that she couldn't
fly in Batman V Superman so when they
did the first Wonder Woman movie they
had to play it like she couldn't fly
until the very end of the film where she
jumps off the roof of the loop it just
seemed like eeap's on going as if she
were flying the reason why you don't see
her running around any of the trailer
footage with her sword because obviously
she's gonna have to fight cheetah at
some point wouldn't she need a weapon is
because they said during this movie they
don't want her to feel quite so
aggressive and one of the most
aggressive things you could possibly do
is show Wonder Woman running down the
street down Pennsylvania Avenue by the
White House brandishing a giant sword so
in terms of fight scenes
she'll mostly just be using hand-to-hand
combat the lasso of truth in her just
regular gauntlets and obviously the
golden armor that you see later in the
trailer for everyone asking about the
special gold armor yes look how shiny
they've been releasing a lot of motion
posters and promos for that it is really
cool it's meant to be a reference to
Wonder Woman's golden war armor from the
comics but within the context of the
movie it does have a special backstory
of its own
remember at the beginning of the first
Wonder Woman movie when Hippolyta is
telling young Wonder Woman the story of
how the Amazonians wound up on thermos
Kyra how they were created how she was
created the story about the golden armor
is that one of Wonder Woman's ancestors
forged the special armor from pieces of
armor taken from her fallen Amazonian
sisters in the armor was built to
withstand the might of an entire army of
regular humans just more backstory
hyping it up as being super super strong
and I think that's mostly in service of
her fighting cheetah once cheetah gets
her full-blown powers and Wonder Woman
suffers some big setbacks because of
that special Black Rock even if Wonder
Woman were at full power cheetah when
she's at full power is able to pierce
one
woman skin that's how powerful cheetah
eventually becomes in the comics but
getting to the big news if you guys
didn't see the announcement
Wonder Woman 1984 original release date
was just canceled this week
finally we were all kind of wondering
what was gonna happen it wasn't coming
out till June and we thought that that'd
be safe from any lingering issues with
the virus and the movie theaters being
shut down the new release date for
Wonder Woman 1984 is now August 14th
at the end of the summer so not that big
of a delay just a couple months Marvel
still hasn't announced a new release
date for the black widow movie yet but I
wouldn't be surprised if they tried to
release it around that same time maybe
early August and just let Wonder Woman
in Black Widow Duke it out in a fight to
the death at the box office they are
filming The Black Adam movie with the
rock starting in August I've already
done a couple of videos and previews for
this we'll add links at the end of the
video they're also supposed to start
shooting Shazam two around the same time
but let me know in the comments Black
Adam vs. Wonder Woman who do you think
would win that fight if Wonder Woman
isn't weak against magic if you have any
big questions or special videos that you
want me to do just let me know in the
comments and as long as you have alerts
enabled for my channel you should see
all those videos when I post them every
one click here to learn about the new
Black Panther 2 teaser inside the Black
Widow movie and click here for that new
Black Adam video thank you so much for
watching everyone stays safe I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]